I don't know look you a date figured up
I think that anyone that's hit those
like I don't know that mark yeah well it
looks like Lindsay Lohan might be
singing a different tune these days
because she just casually called someone
her boyfriend on Instagram and her fans
are in a straight-up frenzy over it
here's what went down on Thursday lilo
shared this pic on insta that's a 33
year old backstage at a music festival
in Dubai standing between a man in a
black jacket and best steel drummer
Chris woody wood who performed with his
band at that night also in the group
shot Lindsay's little sister Allie no
big deal right wrong because Linds
captioned the pic quotes lovely night
with sister and my boyfriend Bader such
a magical night naturally fans were like
um boyfriend in the comment section et
has reached out to Lindsey's rep for
comment on the whole thing but get this
guy's she quickly deleted that whole
boyfriend caption replacing it with a
smiley face emoji a little too late lilo
just a little too late of course we did
a little investigative journalism for ya
and it appears the man in question is
Bader Shamas Lindsay didn't tag him in
the pic and his Instagram profile which
Lindsay follows is private so this whole
thing is still sort of a bit of a
mystery like we have no idea how they
met would you do a dating app I don't
know I don't think so no it is scary now
and so many people say it's the way but
it's great for people that it works for
and that love it but no love for me
personally et sat down with Lindsay in
2019 and she admitted she wasn't really
into the whole dating scene would you
ever date a celebrity again I don't know
look at you and a figure no I think that
anyone that's hit those like I don't
know that mark yeah yet no celeb crushes
no
really do you want to settle down have a
family well yeah of course yeah yeah
well have a family in kids yeah she told
us she's just enjoying living a more
private life in divide so you were
saying that you're not really gone from
Hollywood like you're still in the thick
of it you still want to act
would you consider moving back to
Hollywood no no not not move my life no
I wouldn't you don't think I like having
my private life private that's important
to me which is why I love living in
divide what about music
my sister singing right now so I really
want to support her could you guys
collaborate and do something together
yeah we've talked about that yeah her I
talked about this and it looks like the
long wait for new music could be over in
January a Lindsay Lohan fan account
posted a flashback shot of Lindsay
performing on stage writing hope we get
ll3 this year well Linds took notice and
responded in the comments promising end
of Feb this is the first real talk of
Lindsay's new music since she debuted a
clip of her most recent song xanax in
August I got so sorry
[Music]
you kiss me I can't free Lindsey had
previously teased in June that she was
carving out some time in her busy
schedule to record some new music
posting this pic of herself at the
studio
I am ready Lindsey end of Feb is almost
here and we want ll three of course you
can count on et to be the first let you
know if and when Lindsey drops a new
album or confirms a relationship so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens see you
soon
[Music]